we've size a bit about how cute flow can
help and seen one way to set it up
there's a lot you can do once it's set
up so let's break down some of the
components of cute flow today we'll go
through and give an overview of some of
the biggest components of cube low if
you want to check out the documentation
directly check out the link below to
read more about the components of cute
flow as you've heard us say before
machine learning can be complicated
there's lots of different pieces
involved like handling and validating
your data training your model evaluating
it and eventually serving it since cue
flow handles multiple parts of the ML
experience it's made to be flexible and
composable you can use the pieces you
want to and swap out for the other parts
as needed let's take a quick look at
some of the most commonly used
components available to you will do more
deep dives and future videos first and
foremost there's the user interface you
can think of this as your dashboard to
manage your ml projects you can launch
other components get useful information
about your cluster and find quick links
to documentation if you're working with
multiple teams you may want to set up
namespaces for each team to work in
users who have access to multiple
namespaces can choose which one they're
working on at the top there's a lot more
behind the interface though cue flow
also comes with an integrated jupiter
notebook environment notebooks are
useful for doing quick tests developing
models and writing application code it's
not uncommon for ml engineers and data
scientists to run their notebooks
locally and get constrained by resources
like trying to train a large model on
your laptop cube flow also supports
multi-user support through namespaces so
it's easier to collaborate and manage
access having notebooks in your cluster
makes it easy to run jobs where
resources can be dynamically scaled
we'll talk more about notebooks in the
next video another important component
is ketchup which can be used for
automated hyper parameter tuning hyper
parameter tuning plays a major part in
developing good models and manually
searching a hyper parameter space can
take a lot of effort cat dev helps you
optimize your hyper parameter values
around a metric you've chosen such as
the accuracy of the model it's a helpful
way to find and visualize the optimum
configuration to prepare your model for
production next up Q flow pipelines is a
powerful platform to help you build and
m/l workflows pipelines lets you build a
set of steps to handle everything from
collecting data to serving your model
it's based on containers so each step is
portable and scalable you can run your
same pipelines code across environments
and share it with others and since each
step is independent you can reuse
pipeline steps for different pipelines
and experiments chances are you're
probably gonna want to strain your model
cube flow supports several ML frameworks
for training such as sensor flow and
pipe torch cube flow defines custom
kubernetes resources for distributed
training jobs so you can create a config
file that specifies the details you want
to use for training and let it handle
the rest you have the flexibility to
choose the tools you want to use or
you're already using to train and
retrain your model we'll walk through
some training in future videos of course
your models may not be too useful unless
you can actually make predictions with
them you Flo can serve your models with
multiple frameworks like TF serving KF
serving and Selden Corps you could even
plug in your own serving system if
needed but KF serving can help abstract
most common ml frameworks it's built on
K native a framework for running
serverless apps on kubernetes that way
you can serve your model and access all
the resources you need without having to
handle the complexities directly this is
just a brief overview of the major
components in cube flow there's lots of
examples you can try out for yourself
but we'll also go deeper and talk more
about each of these in upcoming videos
check out the link below to try it out
for yourself and stay tuned
[Music]
[Applause]